pro football talk live continues on this
thursday morning
and wednesday morning brought an
unexpected report from the washington
post about the washington football team
now
last month's item from the washington
post
was much anticipated to the point where
there was
so much ridiculous over-the-top
speculation about the what the
washington post would be reporting
that daniel snyder has filed a couple of
different legal actions
aimed at getting justice for how crazy
some of the allegations were yeah
this time around it just came out of
nowhere right
another 25 on top of the original
15 former female employees of the
washington nfl
franchise claiming they were sexually
harassed during their time there the
culture
uh the the picture that's being painted
gets worse and not better and chris
for the first time because last time
around daniel schneider the owner of the
team remained unscathed yeah
this time around two different incidents
directed
at him one an allegation that back in
2004
he said to a team cheerleader why don't
you go up to the hotel room we have
uh and and get to know my friend better
wink wink not not
he denies that in a separate statement
that was issued and
an allegation that there were and it's
it's
i mean it's almost comical that that
larry michael the
vice president of the team who was the
top media person within the organization
who
abruptly retired one day before the last
article came out right
that he allegedly had the video staff
prepare outtakes from a photo shoot
for the making of the team cheerleader
calendar and the outtakes were revealing
uh with nudity and the outtakes were put
together
allegedly supposedly for snyder
and or the executive team so snyder
is now caught up right in the middle of
this thing and it's alarming
it's disturbing yep and i i
i really want to know
what happens next because
the idea that a lawyer hired last month
by daniel snyder
to investigate daniel snyder's business
and ultimately to investigate daniel
snyder when he hired the lawyer and he's
writing the checks
that's not good enough and the league so
far is going to defer
to the investigation that daniel snyder
has bought and paid for and that to me
chris
is mind-blowing oh that's like we're in
crazyville i don't even understand it
makes no sense to me i mean
none like absolutely none with the nf it
just shows you that there's a different
you know benchmark or you know line
drawn in the sand for the owners as
compared to the players and what's
acceptable
and what's not acceptable and here's a
little wiggle room and that always
pisses me off yeah we're gonna hold the
players accountable for everything
but us you know upper echelon guys we're
gonna be able to kind of do whatever we
want and yeah we'll get slapped on the
hand but we'll just keep going from
there
i mean that makes no sense i don't
understand how the nfl can get involved
in this
you know obviously there's dysfunction
there with the washington franchise with
all that's going down you know over the
last year
you know all these recent stories and
you know regardless of it does seem like
this is a
premeditated hit job on daniel snyder
i'll say that much like somebody has
been very calculated about what they're
doing here to daniel snyder
but when you have this amount of female
employees come
out to say stuff like that you know that
that's hard to swipe under the rug or
look at it like it's a hit
job there was obviously something wrong
with the culture there
for these women to be coming forward and
saying this right now so
very troubling don't understand the nfl
stance at all
somebody is out to get daniel snyder
there's no doubt about that
and you're right where i mean some of
the stories we heard last month and
things like
they were crazy so i understand him
being pissed off too
and but but either way this is not a
good look for him and a continuing
struggle for this washington franchise
and see here's the thing if you're going
to take on
the people who publish the crazy
over-the-top stories about you yeah in
an effort to expose whoever it is
that is behind it all and it doesn't
take a lot of brain power which
qualifies both of us
to address this it doesn't take a lot of
brain power to come to the conclusion
that daniel schneider believes one of
his minority partners specifically
dwight schar
is some way caught up in it and they're
trying to prove it through the court
system
but here's the thing if your hands
aren't clean
if there is something that you've done
that can be proven in some context
that you did it
stand down don't go guns blazing
legally after your your pursuers
because they have something to pursue
just because they went too
far in one area allegedly or possibly or
whatever actually can be proven
if there are other skeletons out there
that are going to bring you down
it doesn't make sense to try to pick
that fight important careful daniel
right he denies the allegations he
issued a statement yesterday
characterizing the washington post
article as a hit job
uh in a pejorative sense obviously that
they're out to get him
and that it's not true and that they're
relying upon anonymous sources and
you know there are some people on the
record that there are former employees
brian baker is the name of the
individual who
will tie the outtakes of the cheerleader
calendar video shoot to larry michael
and then to daniel snyder so not
everybody's anonymous
but you know and and here's the other
problem chris
i'll circle back to the independent
investigation because i want people to
understand what really goes on in a
truly independent investigation
and when the nfl does and doesn't use
one but
we're getting mixed messages now from
the team
you get a statement from schneider
issued yesterday basically decrying this
effort to take him down yeah via the
washington post's latest
article exposing further allegations of
sexual harassment
and then the team issues a statement
saying please anyone out there who feels
that they have wrongly been treated
either in the past or currently
please come forward and tell us about it
well
if you're somebody who currently works
for the team
or used to work for the team and is
contemplating
doing something about it even if it is
simply reporting it to the team
now after years of not feeling like
there was anywhere to go
because number one the human resources
staff was
was woefully understaffed at the
franchise and number two the entire
atmosphere
creates the impression that they just
don't care anyway
um what do you do when you have daniel
schneider
basically saying it's all fake news and
you have the team
saying it's not we want to fix this
that that to the average person is going
to cause confusion at a minimum
and at worst it's going to cause the
person to say no
i'm not going to waste my time trying to
make this right
trying to make this complaint because
the guy who ultimately writes everyone's
paycheck
is saying it's all fake yeah so i don't
i don't give any credence to what the
team officially says well no i mean
you're right it's hard to do that with
with the current environment and things
that are going on now i think the
washington team the football team is
trying to
give a a proactive look to their
franchise in the organization to say hey
look
you know yeah i know we haven't been
perfect and obviously there's some
people out there that are not happy with
us
and we'd like to fix that so i think
they're trying to show like some good
faith within that but you're right it
kind of gets
totally you know what what i want to say
just x'ed out or crossed out a little
bit
when the owner is saying you know it's a
hit job and it's all there's all these
issues listen there's obviously people
not happy uh
under the employment you know of the
washington football team and there was
issues there so he's trying to confront
that
now you know is daniel snyder like you
know the model
you know owner and american citizen i
don't know about that either i've been
around the guy a few times listen
you know and do i think he could be a
jerk certainly yes
do i believe and look at all these
stories and believe them
no not right away you know just as a
human being and being around them i go
that doesn't seem like that guy but you
never know i know that
and i never know i'm not trying to make
any excuse i've been around a lot of
like i never thought that guy would do
that
and he did something where i mean yeah
so you never know i'm not trying to make
any excuse so don't don't
don't so we'll see where it goes but
you're right it's two different messages
being sent down on the same day
but but i'm glad you put it that way
because that makes it even more
important that there be a proper
investigation yeah and and here's the
fundamental problem
with the franchise hiring beth wilkinson
an accomplished corporate defense lawyer
who has represented
big money corporations when they have
been sued
for millions if not billions of damages
fighting back
those plaintiffs lawyers to try to
protect the corporate coffers
she is hired by daniel snyder
to investigate the team and now that
investigation necessarily encompasses
daniel snyder
look it's been more than a decade since
i practiced law but
i recall fairly clearly the rules of
professional conduct
and as a lawyer you have a duty
to your client basically
and to put it as simply as possible you
have a duty to not throw your client
under the bus
beth wilkinson is incapable under the
rules of professional conduct that are
uniform throughout the country
she's incapable of engaging in a truly
unbiased and independent investigation
that could lead to the conclusion
that daniel snyder did what he did she
is going to be wired to go in there and
under the guise of an investigation
shape the evidence in a way that would
make it easier for her to present it
in court if and when they're sued and
they very well may be sued there was a
statement yesterday issued through the
office of gloria allred
she isn't showing up on the scene of
this potential crime
not crime but you get my point because
you've got nothing better to do if
gloria allred's there that means
somebody's getting sued
right right so beth wilkinson as she
does her investigation and i've been
involved in these situations before
it's a tough delicate minefield through
which to walk and you eventually get to
a point where you say i can't do it
because i'm gonna be the one
that's called upon to defend you and and
you're paying me
i can't i can't make this public report
that says you're a scoundrel and you did
all these things i can't do it
that's why there needs to be an
independent investigation that's why the
nfl needs to step up and do it
and chris they've done it before they
did it a few years ago with jerry
richardson
and the panthers owner was in trouble
they had an independent lawyer who
investigated it
and it's amazing to me that the league
won't do it well that's deferring
to the lawyer that snyder hired that's
why i wanted to ask you because
i mean you have a you know the the good
italian gut for this type of stuff like
what would be
what in your mind your logic mike florio
your gut feeling
what would be the reason you think the
nfl wouldn't
hire the independent investigator to
this point like that's what i don't
understand i don't even
get the logic behind it it doesn't look
good publicly
it doesn't make sense and yeah it's
doing no nothing good for the shield
at least from my assessment so that's
where i just so
what's your thought there why i don't i
don't know yeah i
don't know i mean here let's let's apply
occam's razor yeah
right uh sure whatever that and and yeah
occam's razor is the principle that the
the simplest explanation is usually the
most accurate
the simplest explanation may be the
nfl's got its hands full with other
stuff right now
the last thing the nfl wants to worry
about right now in this age of coven 19
and trying to get through a football
season
is whatever may happen with the
washington football organization that's
not an acceptable explanation
i'm just trying to understand why they
would not bring in an independent lawyer
to handle this another explanation is
hey they recommended beth wilkinson to
the franchise beth wilkinson has done
work for the league before and of course
that creates a potential conflict of
interest if the league ever moves on
daniel snyder
and tells him you're going to sell and
daniel snyder says no i'm not i'll see
you in court
al davis style that's going to put beth
wilkinson in a tough tough spot
but you know they want to trust that
she's going
to be able to do a truly and they can
say oh she's tough she's a bulldog
she'll go in there and she'll get
everything she needs and
it's whatever she finds and however she
presents it it's still not going to be
as candid
and damning as it would be if it was
somebody who was truly independent
who didn't care whether or not the
person who hired them
feels like they've been betrayed by the
lawyer they hired yeah
that's the problem that's why it's so
obvious to me
it's not difficult i i respect mike
silver of nfl network i.e
of the nfl i.e his paycheck his son by
roger goodell
who came out last night on twitter and
said this isn't difficult
the investigation must be independent
and it must be
and i don't get it and and and yeah i
chris i'm dumbfounded as to why they
they uh won't do it and you know what
what washington has done if this is the
new precedent
the the blueprint for any other team
that finds itself in any
way shape or form teetering toward the
brink of trouble
go hire your own lawyer to do the
investigation before the league can
i mean wouldn't the saints have loved to
have done that with the bounty scandal
wouldn't the dolphins have loved to have
done that with the bullying scandal
wouldn't the patriots have loved to have
done that with deflategate
wouldn't richardson have loved to have
done that with his own issues he
i mean i think he was still out the door
anyway but
uh the this now that snyder and that's
what was so
about the statement from roger goodell
yesterday the first paragraph of roger
goodell's statement
said everything it needed to say these
are unacceptable
accusations this is not indicative of
who we are
unprofessional disturbing and abhorrent
behavior and workplace environment
alleged in the report entirely
inconsistent with our standards and has
no place in the nfl
good fine perfect end it there because
the next paragraph
gives daniel schneider the pathway to
escaping responsibility for it by
letting the lawyer
he has bought and paid for continue the
investigation
and you know look at and it's you know
when i criticize the nfl sometimes
people say you hate the nfl no i love
the nfl i love professional football
i want professional football to thrive i
wanted to be respected i wanted to be
successful
and when things like this happen that
make me scratch my head and say what the
hell are they doing yeah
i feel it's our obligation it's our duty
to tell us it's a flaw we like you at fl
emperor your butt naked on a horse put
some clothes on
right exactly right that that's what we
do do
we don't sit here doing it to talk about
you know the nfl and be
negative and all those things yeah we're
just bringing up questions thoughts
whatever it may be
please fix this nfl we love you that's
all we're trying to do
here yes and i i don't know i don't get
it
but mike you know at the base level i
think you're right where
it's just there's so many things on the
nfl's plate right now they're just like
okay hey we like this per this
investigator
let you know her go down and figure this
out and yeah we'll talk to her on the
phone and see what she finds out we'll
go from there
between colvin 19 and of course the
social injustice issues maybe the nfl is
overwhelmed with just trying to figure
things out right now
excellent point too chris that you've
reminded me of
if beth wilkinson continues this
investigation and with now
40 former employees and counting who
claim they were sexually harassed
when beth wilkinson calls up and says
i'm the lawyer hired by daniel snyder to
investigate this situation
are they going to cooperate with her
right but if somebody calls up and says
i'm the lawyer that's been hired by the
nfl to do a truly independent
investigation and i am not in any way
beholden to daniel snyder and i am not
working for daniel snyder i'm working
for the nfl
and i'd like i'd like you to answer some
questions will you do it
the person is far more likely to
cooperate with that lawyer yeah
than with beth wilkinson who has no
subpoena power
she cannot make any of the former
employees
cooperate with her investigation which
which limits it out of the gates because
if i'm a former employee of the team
and if there are any former employees
out there who are thinking about what
they should or shouldn't do
let me tell you this as your unofficial
counsel don't talk to beth wilkinson
don't cooperate with the investigation
that's being bought and paid for by the
team
because everything you say is going to
be filtered through the lens
of making it as good as it can be for
the team
or minimizing the negative impact for
the team there needs to be an
independent investigation of all the
things i've felt strongly about over the
years chris
as it relates to the way the nfl handles
it its business this is the one
of everything else and my record is out
there it's open we've talked about all
these issues we've offered our thoughts
this is the one i feel the most strongly
about
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports